[Music]
it's good to see all of you here like um
mati just said my name is Vera and this
is Rick uh we are colleagues and we work
at pipol and for the past two years I've
been working on a project which had to
do with 3D objects uh and we used python
to do this that's why we're here today
obviously and for the last half year
Rick joined us and he did u a more
research intensive part of the project
oh you can still join
us and today's talk will focus mostly on
the research that Rick has been doing as
it's quite Innovative and um the most
interesting thing uh well
um um like the title says um we're
working with uh 3D objects and uh we
want to make a prediction with that and
uh this is field of research that uh
it's not much research in and um there
is a lot of research in a 2d setting so
2D would be images there's a lot of uh
neural networks that can work with
images however not a lot that work with
3D objects so um that's what my made
this project so so interesting well I
think most of you know what 3D objects
are we come into contact with those when
we're really young maybe you had a tool
that looked like that and you quickly
learned that you cannot fit a round
shape into the square hole and the other
way around so you quickly learn that
different 3D objects have different
properties uh then you get a bit older
you probably went to high school and you
uh got into contact with those kind of
objects and uh yeah you didn't have to
fit them in the right hole but you had
to calculate uh the shape the area and
stuff like that and uh at least for me
at this point I didn't come into contact
with 3D objects a lot I mean of course
everything is a 3D object I just didn't
have to calculate anything about that um
until our next project or this project
we have been working on and uh this is
just an example of what the 3D object
look when you load it in Python um we
started this project and uh this was the
first uh time I had to program with
these kind of objects so it was all new
to me and I hope it is also for you so I
can teach you something today uh and
we're at pataa so it's focused on how we
did that using
python um during our project we have
been using two uh libraries mainly first
we used triesh and secondly we used open
3D and uh during the project we used
both of them in parallel because tresh
has some functionalities that open 3D
does not and the other way
around um so we had to switch between
the two uh to do everything we
wanted um
yeah thank you for joining we just
started and uh we just gave an
introduction about the the 3D
[Applause]
object
hi um when our project continued we
noticed that most of the functionalities
of open 3D were the ones we needed so we
gravitated more to open 3D and now we
don't use triesh at all um when using
this library of course you need 3D
objects and those are have specific file
types I asked chat GPT what kind of file
types you have for 3D data apparently
there's a lot and that's not really
relevant for today so we'll focus on the
data we had which are STL files and uh
as you can read it's not that's
interesting but um the description says
that STL files are mainly used uh when
doing 3D
printing uh which is also one of the use
cases of our clients so they uh have to
3D print uh the the project they
manufacture um and that's uh the reason
why they have their files in an STL file
type and that's the reason that we got
it as a STL file well it's by data I
want to show some code so I'm going to
show you how you load your 3D object
your STL file into python it's really
impressive you uh load your data or you
import your library and then you uh do a
read triangle mesh and your file name
and you get a mesh object and mesh
object is something I didn't mention yet
so that's what we're going to do now so
this is how you read it and then in open
3D um there are multiple ways to show
your 3D object so one of them is a mesh
uh and there are several others uh and
the different types have different
properties and can be used in different
kind of modeling uh and are uh good for
some use cases and bad for others so
this is the first this is a mesh um and
a mesh is basically a group of points
connected by triangles so the official
name is a triangle mesh but in short
just mesh and you can see that in the
image so uh points connected by
triangles and the pros of this uh type
of uh 3D object is that you can capture
a lot of surface detail and it gives a
quite realistic representation of your
object and this is why it's also used uh
a lot of in gaming uh because it it
makes a good it's good for rendering I
don't know I'm not into gaming that much
but it's used a lot
gaming uh downside is that file size is
get quite large uh and it comes with a
lot of com uh processing complexity
because the points are connected by
triangles so everything depends on uh on
other points as well um so the second
type of data is a bit simpler it's a
point cloud and the name says most of it
it's a cloud made up of points and in
this case the points are not connected
to each other so it's a more simple way
to show your data uh and it's
unstructured because the points are just
like they are XYZ coordinates so they
are not dependent on the other points at
all um downsides are it's harder to
capture all the surface detail unless
you get a really big number of points
but of course if you get more points you
have to um have more calculating
power lastly we have a a voxal grid and
a voxal grid it looks really ugly right
now but that's why I have a better
example you can think of a voxal grid uh
the same as that you do a pixel grid if
you were to work with images so that
looks like this so uh if you have an
image of a dog and you make that a pixel
grid it would look like the thing on the
left if you want to do it in 3D you just
add another dimension and you get a
voxal grid um the plus sides of this
this are that because the structure is
really similar to that of images the uh
a lot of the models that work on images
can be
translated to a 3D setting you just have
to adjust for the extra Dimension um but
that's a really big plus side of the
voxo grid down sides however and the
image shows it already is that your
resolution uh is worse and it struggles
to get your surface detail correctly
because it's all made of blocks and not
of a more it cannot make more round
surface well um these are the basics of
the 3D programming and I want to
illustrate the use case we've been
working on I have to note that uh it's
confidential the true use case that's
why we are working with the the monkeys
that's not our true data set um but for
the points you want to make during this
talk it doesn't really matter if it's
monkeys or cars or any other thing um so
I mentioned this before um if you were
to show this monkey as a voxo g grid uh
then you can use uh prediction
techniques that are also used on images
quite well and one of the things that
works quite well on images is
classifying what's shown on the image um
and this this can be done for 3D objects
quite uh good as well so uh if I were to
give this object to a model and ask is
it a monkey or a seal or an elephant
that's something that is already pretty
far developed in 3D world let's say so
this is not something we have been doing
but it's something that can be done
quite uh no not easily but rather easily
uh we have been been doing something
different uh we have data of monkeys of
5 years ago and we have data of monkeys
uh the same monkeys 5 years later and
what happens to a monkey in 5 years it
grows just like a human does so in our
example monkey he got a mustache uh he
became broader he has a thing on the
back of his head and he developed a
double chin so those are changes that
can happen okay probably not but that
can happen to a monkey in 5 years and
the goal of our research was can we
predict that so given a monkey that
looks like this right now uh can we
accurately predict what the monkey will
look like in five years so we have to
predict how all those points within the
monkey will shift over five years and
where they will be in 5 years and um
that's something that uh well was not
researched a lot and uh there are
multiple reasons uh one of the reasons
uh being that a data set like this so
you have monkeys for five years ago and
monkeys now that's not a data set that's
readily available if you go to kle and
you look for a data set like this you
probably won't find it and um that uh
limits the research that that has been
done on this subject and furthermore
it's pretty specific use case so I think
that also doesn't help with people
wanting to research it however we had to
do that and um I've been working on
different part of the project but Rick
has been doing this so he will tell you
more about about this
yes yes thank you okay and I just
quickly want to mention if you guys have
questions in the meantime just raise
your hand you don't have to wait for the
end of course uh okay so now that we
know uh what objects we are looking at
so we are looking at these monkeys for
now they have some local
Transformations um and we also what we
will do is we will represent these
monkeys using uh Point clouds so we use
these set of points to actually
represent them and then there are
possible ways on how you could
potentially map such a transformation
but what we will look at today is set to
set mapping as we have this um on one
hand you have the untransformed object
and you have a lot of points on them and
you want to find the counterparts on the
transformed object uh and with the idea
that those points would be located at
the same position if there would not
have been any transformation and then if
you know these uh differences you can
compute those and then eventually model
these so that's the idea on how we want
to model these
predictions and so let's get into it you
load your data in uh and it looks like
this so this is the point Cloud
representation of the monkey you can see
it is nicely centered around the origin
and what happens if you load in another
one and then you can see that things go
wrong and even if we add in yeah another
monkey you can see H they are not nicely
aligned with each other and this
actually makes it difficult and
scenarios like this can occur because uh
usually you use sensors to actually
acquire these the data but it could be
that uh because you're measuring objects
over time it could be that you have a
slight orientation uh within your
scanner and then scenarios like this can
occur and of course this is a very
exaggerated example uh but already small
differences can cause troubles because
we want to uh well predict using these
coordinate values so if all the monkeys
would have a completely different
orientation in space uh different point
would uh yeah refer to a different areas
it would be difficult to not only do
forecasting but also to do something
like
classification so another example where
you can see why it's relevant to have
first all the objects aligned there so
this is a 2d example 2D image and then
the left one you see the objects are
nicely aligned and this is not the case
for the right one and if you want to
yeah model this transformation by
mapping points for example you can see
that in this figure you have fewer
points that actually need to be offset
to actually resolve to the transformed
object well it would probably be
possible on the right figure it would
just take more time because there are
more points that needs to be offset so
it will also make life easier to
actually align these
objects so we need to do some
pre-processing steps on these uh 3D
images and these are so-called isometric
Transformations that we need to remove
and examples of them are for example
translation well that's pretty easy to
resolve because you can just Center a
point Cloud uh let's say that we are not
dealing with reflection for now uh you
can have a difference in scale that
could be part of the transformation that
you want to model but it could also be
that you want to rescale your
objects um so let's leave that for now
and then on the other hand you can you
can have yeah you have this rotation and
that's not so easy to resolve
actually so for this we need to rely on
specific techniques and these are called
Point set registration techniques and
what you do there is you have a source
object and a Target object and what you
want to do is you want to align the
source object with the target object so
in our case the target object is the
specific orientation of the monkey and
as you can see the source is slightly
rotated so the objects are not nicely
aligned uh so we need to yeah align them
and we can do this by relying on
algorithms
so one of the most known algorithms is
this so-called ICP algorithm and what
they do there is they find
correspondences on of points on both
objects and if you remember correctly we
also need those later to actually map
the transformation so it's already
helpful to have them as well so it will
yeah first find these correspondences on
both object both objects and that's
usually done by using distance metric
and then when you have these
correspondences you have a second step
and there you try to uh optimize an
objective function and you do that
usually the objective function is
usually the sum distances of these
correspondences and so you eventually
apply rotations to your object so to
minimize that criteria right so I can
see maybe some difficult faces now so
it's always nice to look at an example
and so here we have two actually Four
Points but you can only see two because
they are on top of each other and so
these are these
correspondences if we expand them you
can see it
better and you can see that these
correspondences do not refer to the
exact same area so that's first you
detect these correspondences you apply a
rotation uh so to minimize distances and
also because there will be
nonoverlapping regions you will always
be able to
improve so you rotate this and then you
iteratively do this so again you try to
find correspondences and they already
refer to uh to the better locations
apply another step and eventually you
will have the objects aligned right so
this is kind of the the idea behind
these
algorithms but you can already probably
imagine that things will go wrong if
your object is for example 180° rotated
because then it will be difficult to
actually these correct
correspondences and in those cases you
will often converge towards some sort of
local minimum where you will not get the
objects aligned so for this we actually
need to rely on uh different version of
the algorithm but what is important here
is they use instead of using distances
to match points uh they use specifically
called post invariant features so you
look at specific features that are
always the same despite the orientation
of your points so by actually looking at
neighboring points you can get features
and uh so it considers kind of like
neighboring points you get a specific
feature and then it doesn't matter if
the object is rotated because you would
get the same value in in that position
and in that way you will be able to
match these correspondences and if you
match them correctly you will be able to
actually align the
objects but of course because we at P
data we also want to show some python
code so here you can see an example of
what that would look like um and this
relies on then this this open 3D package
so it has a lot oh yeah question just
interest how would you get if youca on
this
there you mean really for like aligning
the objects or
just comp yeah I think that could also
that could also be an idea to to
not
I I I wouldn't really know uh we haven't
really looked into that also because a
lot of these algorithms have already
been implemented but I I can imagine
that a tool like PCA would also work but
this the nice thing about this is that a
lot has already been research and
implement it so for example by using
this open 3D package you can um yeah as
you can see with basically two uh
functions so the first one extracts
these features that I talked about don't
get lost in this slide uh then in the
second function you actually apply the
registration and you can see that just
with a few lines of code you can already
align these objects so it's not really
difficult uh you can just rely on these
packages so that also shows that it's
really easy to get started and so to
encourage all of you to after today
start working with the 3D
objects but you can also see it's not
that easy because there quite some high
parameter values uh and so yeah you need
to know what you're doing and you need
to experiment a little bit uh with these
techniques so this is then what it would
look like if you align the objects and
as you can see now they are nicely
aligned so this is this pre-processing
step that we need to solve and now we
can actually move on
yeah Global optimization and when it you
apply all of this transformation or a
gry fashion like at this moment what the
best transformation to apply so um this
one so uh for example this ICP algorithm
um this one is just it has a close form
solution so you can actually get the
values uh yeah by using uh yeah I think
principal component analysis and icon
values and those kind of things so I
think that's that's a good one because
it actually relies on these techniques
um and in that way you can just compute
a close form solution and you
iteratively do this so again especially
because ICP is a local algorithm you can
converge in a local setting and so in
that way it's greedy as you cannot
always get an optimal solution but then
again this this other step fast Global
is more of a global approach and then
you often have a higher chance of
actually reaching a global Optimum so
yeah I hope that answered your
question okay so now that we have the
objects aligned that these
pre-processing steps we can move on to
why you guys are actually here so how to
use these Point clouds in yeah 3D
modeling uh and as Vera said there have
already been some uh networks like uh uh
three threedimensional convolutional n
networks that have been applied to voxel
grids because they have this regular
structure makes it very easy to directly
apply
networks um but again voxels they are
memory intensive uh hard to work with um
so what people often also do is they
project data so you have this 3D Point
Cloud you project it to a 2d Dimension
and then you apply 2D model because
there are just more models available for
that but then again it's also difficult
because what projection technique do you
use uh from which angle do you actually
project so that also presents a lot of
difficulties and so we don't want to
step away from this point Cloud
representation we actually want to yeah
use this one because it's close to Raw
data we don't want to convert it to
another
type but yet we cannot directly apply
these
networks uh to point clouds and the
reason why is because
Point clouds have a irregular structure
and so what this means I can best
illustrate this with an example so again
you have two monkeys two objects and you
represent them by a set of points and
your if you look at the first point in
your set it will maybe refer to the same
area uh but if you look at the second
point it could be that it's located at a
different area and so if you do this for
all points you can see that there can be
some inconsistent ordering H even if you
align objects in which you uh use these
pre pre-processing techniques where you
uh match correspondences and you can get
some of them in a consistent order but
you will never be able to match all of
them correctly yeah so you have this
inconsistent
ordering and as we know networks n
networks are permutation in variance so
that means that if you present a
different uh input or sequence to it it
will also give you a different output
value uh so if you would think for
example if you want to predict house
prices uh you have these input features
like uh number of battery rooms and and
those kind of things if you would
randomly switch the order of these
variables yeah you would get a
completely different output every time
and also when you train a network and
you alter the input every time it
doesn't really make sense but this is
actually the case for Point clouds
because we cannot get them in a
sequential
ordering so actually to resolve this we
can use a clever trick that is called
yeah using symmetric functions and
basically with these functions you take
the maximum and these functions Su as
the maximum or the sum where you always
get the same value despite the order
that you present to it so if you would
have uh for example Five Points uh and
you would take the maximum for each
point across all the points you will
always get the same value and it doesn't
matter what the order of the points is
and so by using these tricks it doesn't
matter what the order of the input
actually is and but again if you would
apply this directly to your point cloud
data you have x y Z variables three
dimensions if you apply such a symmetric
functions you just get three values that
doesn't really say much so first we want
to extract uh yeah more features out of
the point cloud and a possible idea on
how you can do that is to uh present
them through an Network you learn a
higher dimensional feature
representation and then you apply these
uh yeah these symmetric functions per
feature so in that
way
okay so in that way H you actually end
up with a just so first you map each
point independently through a network
there's an input size of three and a
higher dimensional output value you do
that for all the points you get some
sort of feature map and if you then
apply the symmetric functions you get
some sort of global feature Vector that
represents your object and then it
doesn't matter what input order you
provided to it so you will always get
the same output
value and so in this way you actually
get a representation for your point
Cloud for the object uh that actually
resolves this permutation and variant
issue and so in that way we could um use
these features um for any task we would
like so we could for example add a
classification component uh but we could
also do forecasting for
example yeah this is maybe in short what
it looks like because I can think that's
a bit abstract if you have
threedimensional points and you map them
to a higher dimensional feature feature
space so just to quickly illustrate what
this actually does let's consider a
simple feature map where you just only
have five points and three features then
if we isolate on a specific feature and
you can basically see this as a function
of the points and you get specific
values yeah if you would then plot these
points with um yeah red being a high
activation value and blue being a low
value you would get something like this
and if you have a lot of features you
have a lot of these overlapping regions
across your object and
if you would then apply for example a
maximum such as this maximum pooling
function the symmetric function you
would just pick a specific point within
this yeah uh area where you have high
values and so in that way basically what
you're doing is This Global feature
Vector just pinpoints specific areas on
your object and so when you combine this
with a network it really focuses on
areas that are useful and helpful for
your task so for example classification
but it could also be
forecasting so this is in short what
this feature representation looks
like yeah this is then how you would
apply such a Max maximum but I think
everybody knows how to take the maximum
so we don't have to spend too much time
on
that so yeah so far we have actually
talked about a lot of theory and we have
not seen a lot of python but still we
believe that it was essential to
actually cover these steps because these
two steps that we've seen um so first
aligning the objects and then the second
step using these uh invar these
symmetric functions to actually solve
solve this permutation invariant issue
and these are far more essential than
showing for
example a a trick where you can deform
isphere into a dolphin so we thought
would be um better also for you guys to
actually focus more on this theoretical
side but still as some sort of bonus to
still mention a bit of python um we have
seen this open 3D package oh
yeah yeah that's a good point yeah so in
this way you actually get a global
representation and especially for
classification that can be really
helpful uh but again if you really need
specific detail uh yeah you probably
need to add more things so what you can
do is for example you can add a skip
connection layer so you have uh
information at a lower abstraction level
so you take the output of one of your
first hidden layers you skip connect
that so what you usually also see in
segmentation networks where you add more
local context to it and you could apply
something similarly but it's true that
uh yeah the eventual output by using the
symmetric functions is more for Global
representation so you will always lose
some uh some information but that's done
with the cost uh of dealing with the
experimentation variance
mul sub of
theage yeah that's actually funny
because this is called Point net and the
authors also introduced a new version in
which they actually recursively do this
and so it kind of has the same idea as a
convolutional Nur network but then you
just directly applying it to points yeah
so that would be something to check out
for
you H so I as last as a last thing I
quickly want to mention this package
which has been published by meta so by
Facebook research uh so again this open
3D package uh really helps with these
pre-processing steps but if you really
want to apply modeling um this package
is really nice because it has first it
has uh specific 3D loss functions that
have differentiable support so you can
use these to train networks for example
uh they also have
specific data structures uh and they
also allow for errogenous batching so if
you have for example multiple objects
that are represented by a different set
of points well usually if you train a
network your uh tensors need to be of
same size so they provide actually
techniques to uh deal with that and then
next to that they also have this cool
example of how you can deform a sphere
into a dolphin so um yeah you could also
check that that out of course um so yeah
we've actually provided you now with the
tools that you need to start modeling
with 3D data yourself uh so we hope we
got everybody uh encouraged to work with
it and excited uh so yeah now it's up to
you to actually start modeling uh 3D
objects and to ask questions if there
are still any questions left but uh
thank you for
listening thank very much uh you mention
that uh this example is for 3D printing
beginning this this concept is related
to okay so um in yeah in the beginning
this these so-called STL files they
often come um they are competed with 3D
printing so yeah maybe you can
answer uh yeah the use case of our
client was to uh they have to 3D print
an object and they have to 3D print the
same object in five years and they have
to measure again like they have to go
back to measure the object again in
order it's a bit weird if you don't know
the context but they have to go back to
measure it again and then they can 3D
print it but they want to be able to
predict how the shape will change so
they can skip the second measuring part
uh and that's why uh it's related to 3D
pining yes but also a lot of data of
course comes from 3D printing because
these slcl files they also are used for
3D printing and so uh you can actually
use these models load them in into yeah
any representation you want so for
example this point cloud of voxal grid
so I think there there's also connection
there with 3D printing how much data do
you need to train your network it really
depends on the case of course and
because usually you have a lot of points
to represent an object so you would also
need a lot of data sets because you
large data set because you also have a
uh like a lot of parameters so I
couldn't really say uh yeah it really
depends on the case but you would need
quite some samples for that yeah but you
need to train the modor from the same
object data uh let's say that this is a
monkey you need the objects from monkeys
only yeah yeah but you could also try to
add other models but then you might want
to use a bit of different techniques
Maybe uh
so like maybe you would want to use
different functions to extract these
feature vectors from from them because
they can be different for example uh so
you could also add more objects but of
course that would make it more
complicated but for example for
classification you could do something
like that
yeah yes yeah what did you deliver to
the client at the end of project
uh yeah this was more of a research part
of the project so um I don't think this
is finished and we we have to develop
that but we had to uh we delivered
another part of the project where we had
to reverse engineer the monkeys from uh
another data set and that's something we
did deliver um but yeah that's not
relevant to this use case but this is
still in in
progress let's say the 3D printing will
you forecast if you want to print a shoe
will you forecast the shoe or the user
to to grow let's say
yeah I think you could do it in in both
ways uh but if you would have the object
I think yeah it really depends because
on one hand you can measure the food for
example and have like a 3D version of
that and try to model that or you have
the the shoe of a user and then you can
indirectly model the growth in a food
for example so I think you could employ
both approaches there
yeah than uh how I also use some uh the
blender API before generating uh 3D
objects but I didn't notice that
especially if you're trying to load in
external data it take extremely long so
I was wondering how the time consumption
was for this actually I've have not
experienced any issues with that I think
you also
no
yeah good to Yes um yeah when you were
talking about permutation inance I
thought like oh I know where this is
going this is going towards graph neural
networks and then
so I'm kind of curious is that something
that you looked into or reasons why you
went this way and not the other uh
there's not really a specific reason for
that but if I remember correctly I think
these graph networks have also been used
but then mostly for these mesh
representations because they have a
little bit little bit more information
also on the connectivity between points
uh then I think these graph networks
also make a bit more sense because you
already have this connectivity
information but then for Point clouds we
didn't really consider it because we
already thought it was also a difficult
case uh also these craft networks were a
bit new to me so I think it was more of
a reference that I didn't look into it
but it could also be something to check
out
yeah uh the text te yeah actually for my
thesis then for example I used Google
corab uh but it was quite intensive So
eventually I was kicked from Google
corab because I was using too much GPU
so actually you need quite some some
Computing resources especially for this
uh byy torch 3D no wait it's more this
side so for this Library they have a lot
of Cuda support so you can really easily
train networks uh using graphic cards
but then if if you just use regular CPU
power it's yeah takes quite some time it
takes a lot more time to actually train
these
networks uh so yeah I did it first on
Google cab and that worked for me so
yeah
yes lab
or yeah so again it depends on the case
if you are classifying for example the
object then you get a class label but in
the case of forecasting uh the output
would be a point cloud and so uh in that
case if you remember from the beginning
we want to map an untransformed point to
a transform point and we basically map
the difference between them and So
eventually you get them like the these
difference vectors for All Points uh and
if you add those then to your un
transformed Point Cloud you get a whole
point Cloud representation so in short
the output would just be the point Cloud
[Music]
representation